[Funny Music]
Yugado: My name is Josh Yogado,
Founder and partner of SGN.
SGN is the fastest growing mobile games development company
Widely in the West.
The company has founded four of us, and then,
The number of employees increased to more than 200 employees.
Our goal is to continue this growth.
Now, we have four games that achieve the highest revenue,
We want to continue to expand our portfolio
Games that earn the highest revenue.
All our products are launched via
Multiple platforms simultaneously.
Getting it right can be very difficult.
If you want to achieve success in the industry,
Make sure your design is repeated
Constantly improving it.
When your game is widely spread, this is very difficult
Because there are tens of millions of players
Who enjoy your game every day.
Casertano: My name is Matthew Casertano,
Senior Vice President of Gaming Operations at SGN.
The test has already helped us move from subjective standards
To objective criteria.
Where the inability to conduct the test was done
Make multiple quality decisions.
Now, using our tools,
We can make quantitative decisions
The loop uses very short comments.
For Cookie Jam, we did a really interesting test of the icons
Where we made a change on the background of the code.
This has resulted in an 8% increase in the conversion rate.
We use a specialized agency in Preferences
Japanese consumers, we have reached the code design
Uses dense pink and yellow colors to achieve
12% better performance in the Japanese consumer market.
Another game we are testing is Panda Pop.
We had a code previously in the form of a small panda
Which flies in the air surrounded by bubbles.
Then our designers came up with a great idea,
As for the small panda, instead of flying,
He was dancing happily among the bubbles.
When we changed the code,
We saw a 25% increase in traffic from organic search results
And a 4% increase in installation rate.
We had a really interesting test of the symbols in Book of Life.
Maria's character achieved a better performance of 10%
More than the code we used earlier,
Which was characteristic of Xiu.
In addition, for Book of Life,
We tested a different version of our description.
We discovered that the version was improved
Directly and concisely a little more has achieved a better performance of 4%
About the existing version that we used in our store.
The store's experiences helped SGN improve the return on investment equation
By improving costs through high conversion rates
And improve the ratio of loan amount to market value through high retention rates.
With every test we have, we learn something new.
Each test provided us with achievable results
Which helped to improve our business.
Yugado: My first advice is
No matter how great you are, you must remain proficient in your business,
And be prepared for innovation and failure.
You should also love what works,
Therefore, we like to play simplified games.
I think that is the essence of successful company formation
And game design that users want to play.
[Funny Music]